because when you were starting off in
wrestling you had a persona that my
right was sort of half-man half-machine
was it yes it was prototype it was awful
yeah so you want to try to find a
persona or here's some more inside
baseball for a gimmick oh where is it
describes you as a character so like
when you walk out people notice you and
they kind of you can describe your
character but these are not gimmicks
these this is real well well I mean if
they work yes that you kind of it's it's
a trial and error process with a lot of
errors and and my first try was the
prototype which was half man and half
machine and 100% crap machine how did
you demonstrate you were a machine well
I used this ability to talk rather
monotone and would say things with aura
tative and just when I said I would kick
your ass at the fairgrounds on Sunday I
would rewind it and say it again for you
only in veins I would kick your ass at
the fair you know but it worked on one I
hope yeah success as John Cena imagined
that I figure I need to come up with
some sort of name doesn't everyone every
wrestler has a name yes and people think
that like hey man how'd you make up the
name John Cena like no dude out and made
up like dick hammer bush or something
cool
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no one's letting you go out with that
now but they actually think that John
Cena is a gimmick name but no that's
actually through all the the
presentation that is WWE I'm Jamie I
used to love wrestling when we were much
younger about the same time as
transformers back in the day we had Big
Daddy the giant haystack loved it I
thought it's just fantastic by the way
I'm John Cena like to have signature
moves and one of yours is the you can't
see me that's great is that true that
came out of your family somehow yeah I
was I was dared to do it so I was
actually making the music for my own
theme song that you just so heard and
finally serenaded me - thank you very
much and we played it for my brother and
the first time he heard it this was the
the $0.50 crew had a really popular song
called in the club and he heard it the
first time instead of dancing like he
was our litmus test to see what songs
were good what songs are bad he did this
you know my dude what are you doing it's
like now everybody does this man
everybody does this and I guess this is
from 50 Cent's video he's like you won't
do it on TV it's a fail do I gotta lose
I'm gonna fire me of course I'll do it
on TV but instead of doing this I did
this and now for 15 years because of a
dare I've been doing this and I'll do
you one better people actually think I'm
invisible there will be people to look
at this couch and be like why is there
nobody next to McConaughey
John Cena would be there but we can't
see him so you never know
you remember hacksaw jim duggan king
kong bundy and iraq yours and brother
care Von Erichs he carried the cloth I
get kicked out of her calcium in
Shreveport for pelting skandor akbar the
bag of tomatoes on the age stand our
Akbar was a man dressed as a sheik that
used to throw fire yes man is King Kong
Bundy it was like 484 pounds and
remember there's Missy Laird smart son
no no no the green faceless but green
mister they sound really good good stuff
entertained I'm John Cena
[Music]
[Applause]
you